- [Instructor] - Hi, everyone.
Today, we're gonna talk
about chromosome pairs.
But first, I've got a question for you.
Between a black mulberry plant,
a Guinea pig, and a human being,
which organism do you think
has the most chromosomes?
The mulberry plant has green
leaves and delicious berries.
The Guinea pigs are adorable, tiny mammals
with multiple body systems
and humans have incredibly powerful brains
and the ability to form
complex social relationships.
Before I tell you the answer,
let's learn a little
more about chromosomes.
Chromosomes are structures that
contain an organism's genes.
And genes are the units of heredity
passed from parent to offspring
that affect an organism's traits.
Chromosomes, and the genes they contain,
are located inside an organism's cells.
In multicellular organisms,
the chromosomes are found
within the cell's nucleus.
Many species have chromosomes
that come in matched pairs.
For example, here's an image
taken with a microscope
of chromosomes from a
typical human body cell.
The chromosomes are laid
out in an organized way,
allowing us to see that
humans have 46 chromosomes,
which can be organized into 23 pairs.
Each of these is a pair of chromosomes.
This is one chromosome,
and this is the second chromosome.
These paired chromosomes are
called homologous chromosomes.
Homologous chromosomes have
the same size and shape.
They also contain the same
genes in the same locations.
Remember, an organism's
genes affect its traits.
Genes often come in different
variations, called alleles.
Different alleles of a gene
can cause different versions of a trait.
In an organism, a pair
of homologous chromosomes
may have the same allele for a gene,
or they may have different
alleles for a gene.
To help us understand this,
let's take a look at
an illustrative example
using pea plants.
Pea plants can have
pink or purple flowers.
These colors are determined
by two different variations,
or alleles, of a single flower color gene.
Pea plants have a copy
of this flower color gene
on each of two chromosomes
in a homologous pair.
A single pea plant may have
two copies of the pink allele,
two copies of the purple
allele, or one copy of each.
The color of flowers that
the pea plants end up with
depends on how the alleles interact.
But we'll cover that in another video.
An image like this one,
of an individual's chromosomes,
lined up in an organized way,
is called a karyotype.
Scientists and medical professionals
can examine an individual's
karyotype under the microscope
to see if they might
have a genetic condition.
This could show up as size differences
between chromosomes within
each homologous pair
or the presence of an extra chromosome.
Now that you're a little more
familiar with chromosomes,
let's return to the question I asked
at the beginning of this video.
Between black mulberry plants,
Guinea pigs, and humans,
which organism has the most chromosomes?
Any guesses?
The black Mulberry plants do!
These plants have a
whopping 308 chromosomes.
Guinea pigs come in second
with 64 chromosomes.
And like we said earlier,
us humans only have 46 chromosomes.
So we come in third.
Are you surprised?
Believe it or not,
humans, with their big brains
and complex social structures
actually have far fewer chromosomes
than many seemingly
less complex organisms.
Are black mulberry plants
more complicated than we perceive?
Perhaps.
And perhaps there is more
to understanding the role chromosomes play
in determining traits.
That's it for today, thanks for watching.